is there a political solution in the US
to avoid the end of Empire or is it a
function of physics and I think this is
a big part of like Sax's point of view
that there's a solution we need to
change these people or are there too
many call it conflating forces social
forces economic forces that all kind of
Rise and Fall together that and it
becomes an inevitability that there's a
cycling
um there are pre-existing conditions
that represent challenges so for example
the amount of debt that we're in
represents a you can't pretend it it
exists so it represents a challenge
there are a lot of these challenges but
it is not inevitable what is needed is
first of all a strong middle okay to
bring the country together in terms of
rather than to have this fighting
because if if we continue the way we
will we're going to have a conflict and
then there needs to be a good
engineering exercise that's going to
produce but has to be bipartisan has to
be bipartisan with that strong middle
taking control of the extremes because
neither side's going to win a great
Reformation so and that
Reformation has I think should take the
form of like if if I was President of
the United States what I would do is I'd
have bipartisan cabinet I'm not I'm not
running for president